sandra new york city mayor bill de
blasio setting a target date as you
mentioned at the top of the show to get
the big apple
up and running at full capacity listen
here
it's time to set a goal for a full
reopening in new york city
and that goal is july 1st we are ready
to bring new york city back fully on
july 1st
let's bring in our dr marty mccary
professor at johns hopkins school of
public health and a fox news contributor
he did issue the caveat there
let's set a goal i'm sure he'd like to
get it open on july the first but if new
york city can do it
and new york city being a blue city in
new york being a blue state lagging
behind a lot of red states in red
cities might that dr mccary influence
some other blue states in blue cities
to get back up and operate i hope so but
new york has been lagging behind you
know the rest of the country
has a lot of population based immunity
right now but five states have been
lagging they've had outbreaks among
young people and they saw a surge new
york is one of those but cases are down
60 percent over the last four weeks in
new york
and people have a right to ask now that
roughly 75 percent of adults have
immunity
54 with vaccination and about half those
unvaccinated with natural immunity are
we really in a state of emergency when
you have low level of cases
and the number of cases right now in the
united states is below that of a mild
flu season
daily cases and new hospitalizations so
we have a distorted perception of risk
and the cdc needs to issue more guidance
on reopening
not just on closures all right well
mayor de blasio also giving parents a
reason to hope maybe that schools will
be fully
open and not too long from now here's
what he said on that front listen
let me tell you something for september
full strength
no question my mind every single child
can come back to the classroom
and do so safely and that's really what
we need
we need everyone back in school
another goal there september is new york
city schools may get back to
full in-person learning i guess the
question is dr mccary
why not now why wait until september it
should be now it should have been
actually
a long time ago but i think what you're
seeing is that policy makers by nature
with policy
set things that are basically instituted
indefinitely and they make long-term
plans but the situation with covet has
been fluid
and if you look at the numbers in the
united states and even in new york
i mean gosh there's a tremendous
plummeting in daily cases the threat is
low
and i i wish people would not just talk
about the
so-called safety of kids being out of
school but the harm right this
let me know if you ever hear the cdc
director or fouchy talk about
suicide or the harm of profound
isolation those are consequences and
alternatives of closures
you mentioned guidance just a second ago
dr mccary which brings us around to sort
of the water cooler talk of the day and
that is
why were all of those peoples in the
house of representatives last night for
the president's speech
wearing masks when most if not all of
them were vaccinated and the cdc
guidance from its website says you can
gather indoors
with fully vaccinated people without
wearing a mask
or staying six feet apart they were all
wearing masks some of them might have
been wearing two
and they were a long way apart from each
other what was that about well look we
have a completely distorted perception
of risk right now
it's sending the wrong message we need
to send a message that you can
be liberated after you get a vaccine and
you wait a month for that immunity to
kick in
really good article in the washington
post this morning by dr lena nguyen
basically saying it's sending the wrong
message now this is a bipartisan issue i
don't think anyone would accuse her
of being conservative she was head of
planned parenthood she was a democrat
public health commissioner
people are coming together right now
they're frustrated and they're saying
this is contradicting the exact message
we're trying to send
you know great minds think of like dr
mccary because i'd actually pulled a
quote from that let's put it up on the
screen leaner nguyen writing in the
washington post
with masks and distancing biden's speech
sent the wrong message
about the power of our vaccines there's
still a little bit of vaccine hesitancy
did that fuel it even further last night
it did look if we
really want to be serious about
addressing hesitancy let's stop talking
about vaccine mandates
let's respect those who choose not to
get the vaccine some have a good reason
they have
prior covet infection and they've got
natural immunity let's
give rewards and privileges for those
who get vaccinated
let's create more walk-in clinics to
eliminate barriers
and let's stop shaming people that
choose not to get it that's a good
strategy
and i think also in addition we should
stop talking about boosters there's no
evidence we're going to need boosters in
the fall and that's hurting hesitancy as
well
you are a voice of reason in a chaotic
world dr martin mccarry as always thanks
so much